>>Steve Grove: Hello everyone and thank you
for joining us today. My name is Steve Grove
and I'm the head of News and Politics at YouTube
and we're very lucky today have Evgeny Morozov
here with us.
Evgeny just wrote a book, as you can see behind
us, called "The Net Delusion: The Dark Side
of Internet Freedom". And as we'll get into
in just moment he holds a very interesting
and I think useful perspective for people
at Google to hear about what he might say
are some of the myths or misunderstandings
about technology and its role in politics.
And so we're very excited to have him here
today. This is part of both YouTube News and
Politics and Authors@Google NY event. Thanks
to Kate up there for setting this up.
I'm gonna start by reading an excerpt from
Evgeny's book. We reached out to Evgeny about
three months ago to come to Google to speak
of course not knowing what would happen between
the time we invited him and the time that
he came. You can talk about Wiki Leaks, you
can talk about Tunisia, and you can talk even
today about Iran or sorry Egypt as being new
data for us to explore and look at within
the context of Evgeny's book. So good timing
for you to be here.
And we'll just do a little bit of Q and A
up here between Evgeny and I and then we'd
love to just have a conversation with folks
in the crowd and I think we have a few people
on VC as well.
So I'm gonna read an excerpt and then we'll
dive right in there, Evgeny. This is from
the first chapter of Evgeny's book which is
titled "The Google Doctrine" ?
[laughter]
>>Steve Grove: and here is what he has to
say.
"Iran's seemed like a revolution that the
whole world was not just watching but also
blogging, Tweeting, Googling, and YouTubing.
It only took a few clicks to get bombarded
by links that seemed to shed more light on
events in Iran quantitatively if not qualitatively
than anything carried by what technologists
like to condescending call 'the legacy media.'
Such virtual proximity to events in Tehran
embedded by access to the highly emotional
photos and videos shot by protesters themselves
led to unprecedented levels of global empathy
with the cause of the Green Movement. But
in doing so such networked intimacy may have
also greatly inflated popular expectations
of what it could actually achieve.
As the Green Movement lost much of its momentum
in the months following the election it became
clear that the Twitter revolution so many
in the West were quick to inaugurate was nothing
more than a wild fantasy. And yet it still
can boast of at least one unambiguous accomplishment.
If anything Iran's Twitter revolution revealed
the intense Western longing for a world where
information technology is the liberator rather
than the oppressor -- a world where technology
could be harvested to spread democracy around
the globe rather than entrench existed autocracies.
The irrational exuberance that marked the
Western interpretation of what was happening
in Iran suggests that the green clad youngsters
Tweeting in the name of freedom nicely fit
in some preexisting mental schema that left
little room for nuance interpretation let
alone skepticism about the actual role the
Internet played at the time."
So Evgeny tell us a little bit about what
"The Google Doctrine" is --
>>Evgeny Morozov: [chuckles]
>>Steve Grove: and why you think it's irrationally
exuberant.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure. Well I was not referring
to the doctrine when I said this.
>>Steve Grove: Right, right, right.
>>Evgeny Morozov: But I mean the idea of The
Google Doctrine I think to me it's just a
useful moniker to describe I think the somewhat
dubious relationship that has now emerged
between the State Department and people in
Washington thinking about issues like Internet
freedom and Silicon Valley and in firms like
Google, like Facebook, like Twitter I did
not mean to zoom in on Google in particular.
I think there is this expectation that since
so much of this infrastructure that is now
used by digital activists all over the world
is built by American companies that that infrastructure
somehow needs to be promoted by American politicians.
And I think again we can debate the extent
to which this is a useful policy orientation
for people in Washington. I think there is
certainly a danger here because this association
between the kind of business interests and
the business agenda of Silicon Valley and
the political agenda of Washington, I think
it may potentially harm both for various reasons
which we're gonna get into.
>>Steve Grove: Well so what is it, why do
you think people get so excited about the
Twitter revolution in Iran or WikiLeaks and
why do you think that excitement is overstated
or over felt?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure. I mean in the case
of Iran I think we have to understand that
again the U.N. sent around different programs
in Tunisia and they are different from ones
in Egypt. If you look at the media reaction
to what was happening in Iran 18 months ago,
I think that reaction, I think that fork was
the role of technology much more than on the
actual political factors that were driving
the events and that were driving the protesters.
And I think it created this very, how say,
myth that somehow all of those protests were
organized and mobilized by Twitter and I looked
at the actual data from Iran. The only entity
which actually fact checked the number of
Twitters if you will in the country at the
moment was Al Jazeera and they could only
find 60 people actively Tweeting from Iran.
And so the majority of them were not in Iran.
Those were Iranian Americans Tweeting probably
from abroad. Again they did play a role in
terms of publicizing what happened, in terms
of getting the story on the radar of the mainstream
media and especially of CNN which did not
cover the protest for the first few days.
But I think if you go and trace, and I do
that in the first chapter, if you go and trace
the kind of claims that were made about the
power of technology back in Iran, I think
most people did think that that was the end
of the regime and it came in part because
so many people were armed with Twits and pokes
and other forms and text messages.
And of course, what happened afterwards, I
think, got completely lost in the media coverage.
And what happened is that since the government
managed to stay in power they actually turned
to social media. They turned to the information
posted to Facebook and Twitter. They even
looked at email, mailing lists --
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: basically and email groups
to identify some of the dissidents, to identify
some of the protesters. They turned to Flicker
actually to fetch some of the photos that
were posted there by the participants themselves
and they circled some of the faces of protesters
that are now in Iraq and they posted them
on government run news media websites asking
people to identify people whom they could
recognize.
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: In a sense, they were crowd
sourcing the gathering of information about
the protesters which was later used in court.
That part of the story did not get almost
any coverage in the media in the West in part
because I think it also reveals a somewhat
ugly side to technology and to social media
in general.
>>Steve Grove: So the net effect of social
media in Iran would be negative in your mind?
>>Evgeny Morozov: I wouldn't go that far to
say that it was negative. Again it did not,
it did not help the protesters to an extent
that many people in the West thought that
it did. It certainly put many of them at great
risk I think without them realizing and recognizing
the kind of risks that they were taking.
Again my theory is that most of the people
who were actively Tweeting and just Tweeting
something or were posting messages on Facebook
may not even have been aware that the government
has the technology to go track them down.
I'm not even talking about Deep Packet Inspection
technology which supposedly was also used
in Iran to look at the traffic. I'm talking
about very basic stuff looking at social media
sites.
I just don't know what we gain by saying it
was positive or negative. It just didn't play
that much of a role in Iran in getting people
out into the streets. I think to me the most
interesting part about what happened in Iran
was the kind of media and public reaction
that it produced. And I think it did reveal
a lot about how we think about the liberating
power of technology. I mean so to me the most
interesting part was the public discourse
in the West about what was happening in Iran
not necessarily the way for which it was used.
>>Steve Grove: It's interesting you say that
because there was headline after headline
after headline calling this the "Twitter Revolution"
or the "YouTube Revolution" or whatever it
might be and of course the native video played
a lot into that I think in terms of --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>Steve Grove: people having a galvanizing
thing that they could point to. Why in your
mind as your researched in the book ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>Steve Grove: that whole phenomena -- why
are those of us in the West or in America,
why were we so prone, if in fact this --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>Steve Grove: there is a net delusion, that
it's a delusional viewpoint -- why are we
so prone to have it? Why was everyone so excited
--
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: about technology if, in fact,
there was only 60 people Twittering from inside
Iran and the net effect was ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>Steve Grove: difficult for many activists?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um. Um-hum. Well I mean
some of it I think has roots in just how we
think about the liberating power of technology,
not just the Internet. Again I have an entire
chapter in the book looking at the kind of
intellectual assumptions that so many pundits
in America made about the power the technology
played in supposedly ending the Soviet Union.
There is a very rich tradition of journalists
and politicians in this country claiming that
it was the -- first of all it was Ronald Reagan
who ended the Soviet Union, but this -- and
second, it was the Voice of America and Radio
Free Europe and the Western broadcasts and
then the fax machines and the Xerox machines
that were smuggled into the Soviet Union to
be used by dissidents -- that eventually caused
the Soviet system to collapse.
When you look at some of the columns written
recently even about Tunisia and Egypt, you
still see a lot of columnists making that
particular point that it was the free flow
of information that undermined the Soviet
Union. And I think there is definitely a role
that Western broadcasting certainly didn't
hurt the chances of the democratization in
the Soviet Union right. The Samizdat literature
certainly helped to create and shape the culture
of resistance in the country. It was not the
driving force by any means. Most historians
now would probably credit the role of the
economy and the fact that the Warsaw Pact
could not compete with NATO. I mean there
are all sorts of structural factors which
caused the Soviet Union to collapse but, however,
it's just as a narrative. It just makes for
such better copy and journalism to credit
the role of dissidents with the fax machine
then some trade statistic and the Soviet economy.
But of course when that was many of the stories
glorifying the role of the user, glorifying
the role of the dissident. And I think many
of the same assumptions now are being rediscovered
when we talk about the power of blogging --
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: and the power of the Internet.
I mean I spent some time analyzing Hillary
Clinton's big speech last year on Internet
freedom.
>>Steve Grove: On 21st century statecraft.
>>Evgeny Morozov: [coughs] Well I mean technically
it was a speech on Internet freedom and she
did another speech on 21st century statecraft
--
>>Steve Grove: Oh, okay.
>>Evgeny Morozov: but it was the museum speech
--
>>Steve Grove: Yeah.
>>Evgeny Morozov: on January 21st. And you
look at that speech and the way she described
some of the problems ahead in terms of Internet
freedom are all framed and phrased in terms
of the Cold War vocabulary. It's all about
the information curtain that's descending
upon the world. It's all about virtual walls
that are replacing the Berlin Wall. It's all
about bloggers being dissidents to point out
who are engaging in basically production of
samizdat which again she takes to mean basically
blogging and Twitting --
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: and all of that. And I think,
I mean, some of this is useful in terms of
elevating the subject to, in terms of sort
of institutional politics in the State Department.
If you label bloggers as dissidents, probably
anyone working on Internet freedom will automatically
get more traction and it just will be much
easier for them to get things done.
But on the other hand, I'm just not sure that
claiming that bloggers are dissidents is helpful
in terms of grasping the actual environment
in countries like Russia or countries like
China or even Iran. We do have a lot of bloggers
who are actually much more conservative than
their leaders. I mean there are plenty of
bloggers in Iran who hate Ahmadinejad --
>>Steve Grove: So in some ways --
>>Evgeny Morozov: because he's not harsh enough.
>>Steve Grove: So in some ways, you're taking
contention with the sort of evaluating technology
is inherently good in some ways whereas --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah. I mean yes, but also
evaluating bloggers and blogging as just a
logical continuation of those older processes
of Samizdat printing, Samizdat distributing
banned literature. I mean again it's useful
to an extent but you have to realize that
many of those countries have changed so tremendously.
Russia and China and even Iran have changed
a lot since --
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: 1989. I mean they -- it's
no longer just the battle of the bad guys
who are in the government and the good guys
who are opposing the government. I mean they
have much more complex political and social
forces out there in Russia. It's the Nationalists
who make the best use of technology whether
it's YouTube or whether it's blogging or whether
it's Twitting. I mean they are much better
at organizing, getting people into the streets,
and having race riots as we saw in November
in Moscow, for example, right? And if you
just imagine that all of those Internet users
in Russia who are using this channel some
platforms are dissidents, you're just missing
out that many of them aren't and many of them
have agendas which probably look even more
anti-democratic than the Kremlin's one.
>>Steve Grove: We should back up for a second
and tell people in the room about your own
story --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: you're from Belarus --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yes.
>>Steve Grove: you didn't start out with this
opinion necessarily but --
>>Evgeny Morozov: No.
>>Steve Grove: this is sort of a conclusion
that came to you after some thinking.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: Tell us a little bit about
how --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: you came to write the book
--
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: and --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah so I come from Belarus
which as some of you may know is not probably
the most democratic country in Eastern or
Central Europe. So I've always been fascinated
by the questions of basically democratization
and how do you actually promote democracy
in a country like Belarus without necessarily
having to send in the Marines or --
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: [chuckles] or anything of
that sort. So I've always been interested
in sort of finding some softer morals in which
to open up the country and to promote democratic
values. So I did get very excited about the
power of technology and love to point out
around the year I would say 2005, so when
there was still a lot of excitement in the
U.S. about the power of new media. Remember
it was shortly after the 2004 Presidential
Campaign was still lot of talk of Howard Dean
making this excellent --
>>Steve Grove: So you went into the media
--
>>Evgeny Morozov: use of media. So I thought,
"Gee, I mean great. Let's just use all of
that, let's use blogs and social networks
and all of those new platforms to basically
push against the government. So I joined an
NGO called "Transitions Online" which was
based and still is based in Prague which was
not only active in Belarus. They were acting
throughout the former Soviet blocs in like
29 countries including --
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: western Europe and places
like Mongolia even. And eventually I became
Director of New Media which meant that I traveled
throughout that region, gave trainings to
a lot of bloggers and journalists and activists
on how to use blogs and social networks to
push for democratic change, but also oversaw
a lot of projects that we got funded to do
by the likes of National Endowment for Democracy
in Washington or all sorts of other funders
that traditionally take government funding
--
>>Steve Grove: And so you're out there training
bloggers and dissidents --
>>Evgeny Morozov: [coughs] And supervising
some complete projects --
>>Steve Grove: And what were you learning?
>>Evgenhy Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: Were they --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Well, I mean for them it
was easy I mean they wanted to promote their
stuff, they wanted to mobilize people, they
needed to know how to push the ideas out there.
I ended up in Tajikistan in a training where
I brought this fancy PowerPoint. It was Flicker,
YouTube, all the goodies about to [inaudible]
and ended up in a room of people whose only
experience was the [inaudible] was basic chatting.
They're still using all that chat software
from the 90s and they were operating in an
environment where the only national paper
comes out once a week on a Thursday and it
has no photos in it, just text. It was very
hard to talk about the benefits of Web 2.0
to activism to that audience.
But in other cases it was much better received
because they were users. The problem with
that as I discovered after three years of
doing this, is that the governments themselves
were becoming much more strategic about their
use of the Web. It was not just about blunt
Internet filtering. They were doing much more.
They were not only banning access to certain
URL's; they were beginning to pay bloggers
to spread their own opinions and propaganda.
They were beginning to turn to all sorts of
data mining firms to learn about trends of
sentiment analysis in social media understanding
sort of what people think and how they behave
and what things are happening.
Even in Russia you saw pro [inaudible] oligarchs
suddenly buying new media platforms, you had,
LiveJournal was bought by a Russian guy basically
and now is owned by Russians right. So all
of those seemed kind of, at first they seemed
very interesting, I mean the other side, the
enemy was doing something as well. But by
2007 I think early 2008 I just realized that
we were kind of losing the fight. In addition
to that many of the projects that were funded
by American donors in countries like Belarus
or San Alaysia actually had the opposite effect
because what happened is that you had this
big foreign funder come in and hire all the
most talented new media entrepreneurs and
put them on grant money and basically kill
all local innovation because now they didn't
want to build a Website unless they got a
big grant. And once they got the grant, they
would make sure that it fails because they
can get another grant to fix all the problems
right. So you ended up in this cycle where
all of the best people who could be working
on all these wonderful projects ended up working
with NGO's that were just taking money from
the West and not contributing much. [coughs]
>>Steve Grove: So if the Web is a platform
where any number of things can happen: good,
bad, ugly, oppressive --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Uh-huh.
>>Steve Grove: democratic, revolutionary there's
a lot of things that can take place on the
Internet. What your book seems to be saying
is, "Hey, wake up. Don't just concentrate
on the good stuff, there's a lot of, there
are a lot of -- challenges to the Web --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: and politics. But that's just
my sense of it. Why did you write the book?
What is the, what do you hope someone ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: gets out of your argument?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah I mean to me the primary
interest of course is still policy makers.
It's not the general kind of Internet --
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: sort of media, new media
public. To me the big, the primary market
for the book is Washington or London, and
Brussels. It's people who are thinking about
ways in which to integrate new media and which
to integrate the Internet into the existing
sort of kind of foreign policy making apparatus
if you wish.
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: And the problem is that
when I look at a concept like Internet freedom
which Hillary Clinton began to promote last
year I just think if I have to evaluate it
as the new pillar of U.S. foreign policy as
she claimed it was, I think it's just a very
weird concept. Not only does it not capture
the kind of the darker side of what's happening
in terms of business or right there inside
governments themselves very actively using
the Web. I think it's also deaf to domestic
policy and to what's sort of the U.S. government
itself has been trying to do with the Internet
domestically in the last three or four years.
If you look at the evolution of your domestic
American approach to the Internet, all the
argument has all been about great Internet
control not great Internet freedom. Whether
it's a matter of FBI and NSA trying to convince
American companies to build back doors into
the system or it is going about the main names
of people spreading pirated materials online
or whether it's a matter of going after companies
that assist WikiLeaks. I mean you look at
all of that and it makes America look extremely
hypocritical when on the one hand they are
touting the virtue of Internet freedom abroad
while kind of doing the exact opposite domestically.
And so to me the, there are, we can debate
how to resolve this problem domestically,
but to me the fact that now we have rushed
into this quest of promoting Internet freedom
without having thought about how the State
Department should structure its relationship
with American companies, how they should structure
their conversations with other agencies of
the U.S. Government which are trying to do
the opposite of what they're doing. All of
those I think are big questions that need
to be addressed because it's very easy I think
and I think that's in part what has been happening,
it's very easy to be moving in the wrong direction
at the great speed, right. And I think --
>>Steve Grove: So what is wrong --
>>Evgeny Morozov: [coughs]
>>Steve Grove: with the, what is wrong with
the U.S. foreign policy's relationship with
American technology companies or --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: their understanding of, because
access to information --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: or Internet freedom --
>>Steve Grove: could be applied to Radio Free
Europe 20 years ago --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yes.
>>Steve Grove: I mean that's a value --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure. But I mean --
>>Steve Grove: that's basically American.
>>Evgeny Morozov: to me the question is do
you as Google or does Facebook or Twitter
want to be seen necessarily in Russia or China
or Iran as the Voice of America or Radio Free
Europe right?
>>Steve Grove: Very different in this context
then --
>>Evgeny Morozov: I know but still I think
it's a big question because this is how you
would be seen intrinsically right. And I just
don't know whether it's a good idea to trust
you to be Voice of America because you're
driven by completely different set of motivations
and incentives, right. So this is one problem
that I see.
The second problem is that look, look at what
happened in the last three years in terms
of sort of what the State Department has been
doing, Voice of America companies. I mean
you all know probably very well about [inaudible]
of technology delegations.
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: They take the CEO's of American
companies send them abroad. Again there was
a dinner in which Hillary Clinton hosted for
some of the CEO's at the State Department
and the question there is why should, to me
the question is for example, why should the
CEO of Twitter or the founder of Twitter be
invited to the State Department when Twitter
did not join the Global Network Initiative?
A very simple question. Why should the State
Department be kind of promoting some of those
very companies that do not want to sign up
to certain standards of behavior resisting
the Department itself? --
>>Steve Grove: And just --
>>Evgeny Morozov: as a kind of champion right.
>>Steve Grove: explain the GNI for those here
who may --
>>Evgeny Morozov: I mean it's basically an
industry wide agreement of technology companies,
certain NGO's which Google is a member of,
which specifies how they should behave when
it comes to certain aspects of freedom of
expression, how they should treat --
>>Steve Grove: Right.
>>Evgeny Morozov: users and user data and
how they should interact with governments.
>>Steve Grove: Right. So in some ways --
>>Evgeny Morozov: [coughs]
>>Steve Grove: it sounds like you, one of
your concerns is private companies playing
a very public, private companies whose platforms
are made for profit because they're probably
companies being sort of used at the forefront
of public and international discussions --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yes, but also I just don't
see how exactly -- there is no firm approach,
there is no coherent approach. You have on
the one hand the State Department accusing
or being very critical of Cisco's role in
providing technology to China which facilitates
their censorship and then on the other hand
10 months ago giving Cisco an innovation award.
And it's very hard again to reconcile those
two, even though it may have been done by
two different departments, two different bureaus
within the State Department.
But the other thing I think you have to remember
that if you look at the kind of perception
that the State Department has created in terms
of how it views American companies, it's not
a very healthy perception. And here I have
to speak critically of your colleague, new
colleague now, Jared Cohen who used to work
at the State Department.
Again you look and track some of Jared's statements
where he would say things like, I'm quoting
"Facebook is the most organic tool for the
market's promotion the world has ever seen."
And when you say things like that when you
work for the government, chances are a lot
of governments are concerned with America
promoting democracy in their backyard. Chances
are it's not gonna help either the government
or Facebook because the governments will try
to squeeze out American companies or try to
replace their services with local, more pliable,
and easier to control alternatives. Right
so --
>>Steve Grove: So let's back up --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: for a second and look at sort
of how this relates to Google because you're
at Google and I'd love --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: to dig a little bit more --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: deeply into that. Our mission
as you know is to organize the world's information
and make it --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: universally accessible and
useful. And I think most people at Google
don't think about that as like a business
strategy but just like a true good, --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>Steve Grove: right. Like more information
is better for the world and having --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: more transparency and more
access to it is good for our users and good
--
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: for our citizens. Do you agree
with that? I mean would --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: you take intention with that
as a truth and what --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: problems or challenges do you
see with that and what would you hope Googlers
know about your --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: feeling on that question?
>>Evgeny Morozov: But I think it doesn't really
matter whether I agree with that. The question
is how will that mission be perceived abroad
by certain governments and how will that mission
be interpreted in light of certain events
or relationships that Google has or does not
have with the U.S. Government.
Because again you look at Tunisia and Egypt
those countries have enjoyed American support.
So no one would actually, no one inside would
think that the protests there were actually
organized by the CIA. That would not seem
like a realistic hypothesis. In the case of
Iran or China or Belarus or many other countries,
that would seem like a realistic hypothesis.
So when some protests break out, the initial
assumption is that, "Hey they must have been
orchestrated by America, by the State Department
training young activists abroad or training
bloggers or training cyber activists." You
name it. And this is where I think you have
to understand how your own image will be perceived.
I mean it will not be, you will not be judged
against your mission. You will be judged against
your existing relationships whether those
are with the State Department of the U.S.
Government or with dissidents or with activists,
right.
And again I'm not sure that this realization
is -- I mean I'm sure it's there I'm just
now sure how acutely you are aware of that.
[coughs]
>>Steve Grove: You mentioned Tunisia and Egypt
and I would love to hear just your thoughts
on the events of the past few months and how
it relates to the project of this book.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah. I mean in some sense
if you look at the sort of public reaction
to what happened particularly in Tunisia I
think there was still quite a bit of hype
in terms of people calling it a Wikileaks
revolution or Twitter revolution. So in some
sense if you look at the public discourse
I mean it has improved somewhat I think people
are much more reluctant to call it a Twitter
revolution as they were in Iran but some of
that was still there.
In terms of the use of new media for organizing,
I never denied that it would be used right
and again when the right time comes it can
do wonders. It helps to have not just Twitter
but army on your side and if you do of course
social media will be a great role in terms
of publicizing protests.
The problem is that [coughs] if the government
doesn't fold then you end up in a situation
like Iran where the government also turns
to the same platforms to basically make its
crack down much harsher because of it has
access to all the data. So again it's all
about political and social conditions on the
ground and not so much about technology and
I think you have to remember that.
In Egypt I think the situation is more or
less familiar. Many of these groups were in
place three years ago many of them Facebook
groups especially. Many of them did not appear
overnight and many of the digital networks
have been in place for some time already.
Again the reason why I think they played such
a big role in terms of publicizing protest
before data was cut off again was because
the political situation was right and the
30 years of Mubarak's rule were bound to end
sooner or later.
So again I think it will be a mistake to attribute
what has happened there to technology because
it's not driven by technology. And to me the
question is in an age where everyone is on
Facebook and Twitter and is using Google,
I mean how do we expect a revolution to look
like? I mean it's normal that all of them
will have some --
>>Steve Grove: But is there something more
inherently personal about --
>>Evgeny Norozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: these things that unfold when
there's a way to connect to them through social
media? I mean to --
>>Evgeny Norozov: Uh-huh.
>>Steve Grove: watch to watch Neda --
>>Evgeny Norozov: Yes.
>>Steve Grove: pass away in the streets of
Tehran --
>>Evgenhy Norozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: as an American sitting at your
laptop at your home --
>>Evgeny Norozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: is a very personal and chilling
moment that I think probably connects people
in a more deep way to an event --
>>Evgeny Norozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: than say seeing a news wire
story or --
>>Evgeny Norozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: and so --
>>Evgeny Norozov: But again --
>>Steve Grove: whether or not the regime toppled
--
>>Evgeny Norozov: Yeah.
>>Steve Grove: there's more people in the
U.S. probably that feel a connection to what
took place in Iran I would argue ?
>>Evgeny Norozov: Uh-huh.
>>Steve Grove: because of that ?
>>Evgeny Norozov: Sure.
>>Steve Grove: connection and in the long
term is that a good thing?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Well again the question
is to what extent will that influence a load
of U.S. foreign policy. You may argue that
there will be cases where, and now we're seeing
images from [inaudible] --
>>Steve Grove: Right.
>>Evgeny Morozov: or Americans feel that they
need to push their government to change the
policy on Egypt. I mean I'm also sure that
there will be cases where similar images will
push America to change its foreign policy
in ways that will not be necessarily conducive
to democracy and democratization.
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: The example I usually give
is the photos that came out of Somalia and
they're of U.S. soldiers being dragged through
the streets of --
>>Steve Grove: Right.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Mogadishu. Again that was
very emotional [inaudible] It led to America
withdrawing its troops in part because the
U.S. public was so concerned and it wanted
to exert pressure right. So again it all depends
on I think the particular case. I'm not, I
wouldn't go as far as to say that the fact
that so many Americans get so emotional about
stuff online necessarily has a good influence
on policy making; no I wouldn't. In part because
it, in some sense, it shortens the distance
between the policy maker and the citizen at
which point we do have to debate the virtues
of direct democracy versus representative
democracy. How much autonomy actually we want
to grant to policy makers.
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: And on many issues I think
we want to make sure that they are transparent
and this is why we have WikiLeaks, but on
the other hand I --
>>Steve Grove: Right.
>>Evgeny Morozov: don't want policy makers
to set policy based on how many ?
>>Steve Grove: Got it.
>>Evgeny Morozov: views each video gets ?
>>Steve Grove: Yeah.
>>Evgeny Morozov: on YouTube.
>>Steve Grove: I don't think that's happening.
>>Evgeny Morozov: [coughs]
>>Steve Grove: It'd be interesting. If that
was the case, Charlie the Unicorn would be
President of the United States.
>>Evgeny Morozov: [laughs]
>>Steve Grove: I'd like to open it for questions
if you have questions for Evgeny, there's
mics here and here and I don't know if anybody
in the VC has one, but feel free to chime
in if you do. Over here, sir.
>>male #1: Yeah, so events teach us many things.
You mentioned Neda dying. It teaches us on
the one hand it inspires us to see that other
peoples potentially dying for freedom perhaps
set an example. On the other hand it teaches
us that running around the streets of a place
like Iran during this sort of event is a really
dangerous thing to do and it may be considered
unwise. There's a good side to that ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>male #1: there's a bad side. And this, the
two sides are in anything.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
As far as sort of the argument that seems
to be made here, it seems to me that a fundamental
promise of democracy is that the voice of
the people will be heard, that their experience
and knowledge will be respected ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>male #1: and that it will be considered
useful. And thus for us to have a democracy,
?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>male #1: we have to ways for people to be
heard. We have to have ways to store and retrieve
information. So it seems to me that sort of
a society or a people's ability to either
maintain a democratic form of government or
to create one if it doesn't exist, is fundamentally
tied to the facility with which they, the
technology that's available to them for sharing
information, for communicating with others,
for storing it and retrieving it, and the
rest.
Given that, it would seem to me that the Internet,
the technologies that we work on etcetera,
we must have them and we probably must have
more of them ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>male #1: of that technology and better technology
if we want to see democracy in the future.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>male #1: It may be that there's some unfortunate
consequences along the way.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>male #1: But no matter how much sort of
unfortunate consequences there may be, ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>male #1: I think we need to accept that
doing more with this technology ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>male #1: is absolutely necessary ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>male #1: and that we should never hold back
?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure.
>>male #1: of building tools that make it
easier for people to communicate, store information,
exchange it, etcetera.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Sure, I mean I think it's
the right direction to think about it. The
question is really I mean it's nice to be
building tools right and it's nice to be building
tools that circumvent censorship, and it's
nice for a company to be doing that and I
think Google is doing a great job.
The question is if you sit at an entity like
the State Department right which has to make
decisions about the allocation of resources
do you want to pour more money into building
tools? Do you want to pour more money into
training bloggers? Do you want to pour more
money into making sure that existing NGO's
and political parties in a country like Belarus
or Azerbaijan or whatever know about new media,
right. And this is I think the question. I
mean there are different levels in which we
have to answer this question. As a private
actor sure you have to be doing as much as
you can and probably on an issue in which
you can contribute the most. It still doesn't
answer how you should go and redistribute
the resources within the State Department
or a government entity ?
>>male #1: But if we want ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: which has a policy based
on what?
>>male #1: If we want democracy in Belarus
?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yes.
>>male #1: and if democracy relies on the
ability of the people to ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yes.
>>male #1: communicate, store, etcetera ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>male #1: then how could we do anything other
than work constantly to increase the facility
with which the people can speak among themselves?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Well I mean [chuckles] there
is no Internet filtering in Belarus right
now so but again I think there is this virulent,
hostile tendency to think that once we build
the tools and once people can bypass censorship,
they will immediately do certain things, X,
Y, Z. And it just doesn't work that way.
And again from the perspective of someone
who wants to spend a pot of money, 10 million
or a million dollars on fostering democratic
change in a country like Belarus, I'm not
sure that building tools is the way to go.
Maybe you want to go and make sure that your
network of activists on the ground knows about
how to campaign, how to resist police pressure,
how to raise money. I mean there are all sorts
of other ways which by the way we knew before
the Internet in terms of how to promote democracy
elsewhere.
So I mean I understand the push ?
>>male #1: But to campaign, to raise money,
to do these things ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yes.
>>male #1: these are all acts that require
technology, okay? The problem here isn't the
technology, the capacity to communicate, to
store and retrieve this is a fundamental requirement
before any of these other things can occur.
If you wish democracy, you must have these
things. So to question whether or not ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah, but if you don't have
the networks of people who take advantage
of this tools, there is no point in building
the tools.
>>male #1: Yes there is because once you build
the tools, once you provide the capabilities,
they will be there for the people to use when
they get in the mood to use them.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Well I mean I wish it was
that simple but again ?
>>male #1: How could it be anything else?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Well because there are elections
in which you need to have to make sure that
you have political infrastructure that you
have political parties that can go and make
sure that there are people after the elections
to show up on the street. I mean the tools
will not get you 5,000 people to show up in
a post-election protest as much as you want.
>>male #1: Okay. Whatever.
Information technology, ?
[laughter]
Information technology is the fundamental
infrastructure for democracy. You cannot ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: But again ?
>>male #1: have one without the other.
>>Evgeny Morozov: no one is arguing that.
You have to think about this from the perspective
of a policy maker who has limited resources
to spend on achieving a certain objective,
right. I mean let's just scrap the State Department
and National Endowment for Democracy and just
empower Google to build tools and then wait
until democracy happens.
>>Steve Groves: So in some ways you're just
saying, "Hey it's more complex than that."
>>Evgeny Morozov: Well yes again ?
>>Steve Grove: That's the crux of your argument
in some way.
>>Evgeny Morozov: I mean yes but I don't even
think I have to make that argument and then
yes of course it's more complex than that.
But again I just don't think that by building
tools necessarily you will be getting any
closer to any of those objectives. I mean
it took, if you look at what it took to get
the Ukrainians to the level of the Orange
Revolution. It took years of funding, years
of hard work, years of training to the activists,
years of making ?
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: sure that the Ukrainian
activists underground can go and learn from
the activists in Serbia who had a similar
event in Georgia, had a similar events a few
years before that. It didn't take Asamas technology
to tax people and tell them where the protest
is. That was the easiest part of the entire
-- so again I'm all for building the infrastructure
just that as a policy maker you probably ?
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: want to have some kind of
a framework where you know how to discriminate
between great tools and great people and ?
>>Steve Grove: Right, right.
>>Evgeny Morozov: great networks.
>>Steve Grove: Let's go over here.
>>male #2: In light of Iran and Moldova with
very strong states that crushed these like
new media ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>male #2: revolutions and I would argue in
Egypt where if the army were called in to
actually crush this they actually would be
able to, where do you see the value in social
media, I guess where are the opportunities
in what puts the states in situations and
sociopolitical ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum.
>>male #2: situations where the new media
actually has the greatest ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: [coughs]
>>male #2: chance to affect democratic change?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Um-hum. Well I mean again
publicizing this event I think, I'm not, let's
look at Egypt I'm not sure that the reason
why the Egyptians blocked the Internet was
to prevent Egyptians from organizing. It was
probably to stop the foros and videos and
medias from getting out. That's the reason
why they're now cracking down on Al Jazeera,
right. Again as Egyptians have shown, you
don't really need a great social networking
infrastructure to have so many people in the
streets of Cairo, again as they proved again
just a few days ago.
So I think there is definitely an element
of making the violence more transparent and
this is what scares so many people in the
government. In terms of the kind of positive
program for social networking, I think again
often there is an assumption that's made that
we don't need to have existing political movements,
we don't need to build political parties,
we don't need NGO's. The moment young people
are online, they will all form their own groups
on Facebook and they will all pour into the
streets and protest. In some case probably
something like that happened in Tunisia and
Egypt but I think it would be over simplifying
to claim that we can expect the same outcomes
to come in, to happen in Russia or Belarus
or in Azerbaijan.
And to me the key question is how can you
can actually make sure that this young digital
goers who are online, who are on Facebook,
do not disengage from the existing political
forces on the ground? Because to me, the risk
and the danger is that we'll see a growing
disconnect between this younger generation
who are on Facebook, who are online and the
older ones which are eager to go online and
protest and get written up and end up in jail
right. And I think looking at my own country
to Belarus I do see a lot of young people
for whom virtual protest has become the kind
of end in itself. They have so much fun ?
>>Steve Grove: Slacktivism as they call it.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yes, they have so much fun
taking a photo of the President and Photoshopping
it and drawing all sorts of mustache or whatever
to a photo and then claiming that it's a political
act and then having a competition in thinking
that it's the greatest act of dissent that
they ever could make. And I think that this
is the kind of activism, slacktivism, I worry
about right.
Again in Tunisia of course there are a lot
of people who are unemployed, there are a
lot of young people who are over educated
and unemployed which of course makes it easier
for them to go out to mobilize. And kind of
like Russia the problems are different and
unemployment is not there to the same extent,
and the oil prices are keeping the Russian
economy afloat so I think making sure that
we don't just create virtual movements that
exist on their own and make sure that we integrate
with the existing ones would be a good way
for social media to kind of advance.
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum. Right.
>>Evgeny Morozov: [coughs]
>>Steve Grove: Over here.
>>male #3: We've been talkin' a lot about
democracy but I think even more important
than that is liberty and if you're not, it
seems to me that if you're not careful you
get the kind of things like in Algeria where
they had a movement for freedom and then it
became a repressive government and as you
mentioned the Nationalists in Russia. How
do you keep things from just being a majority
population stomping on the minority 'cause
it's easier to organize people around things
they hate than about things they love.
>>Avgeny Morozov: Well I mean I don't think
that there is a way. I mean you take the risk
and see what happens. I would probably rather
run the risk of having Nationalists in power
in Russia than see Kremlin continuously in
charge, right. [laughs] So I don't know that
there is a solution. Again you have the same
problem in the U.S. with the Tea Party exploiting
social media very actively and aggressively
for their own purposes right. So I just don't
think that there is an easy answer. Get people
online and see what happens.
My point, the reason why I talk about Nationalists
and all of those other forces that are not
particularly pro democratic in the book is
because the current Internet freedom policy,
Internet freedom agenda is completely deaf
to the fact that some wrong forces may be
in power and that they will need to be somehow
countered online, right.
You have in Russia for example, you have Nationalists
who actually taking census data which is now
also available online and they're taking the
maps published not by Google but by Yandex
in Russia and they're creating matchups. They
take census data about where national minorities
live in a particular Russian town and they
match it up with the map and they basically
show where minorities live in a particular
Russian town, encouraging their supporters
to go and basically beat up anyone who lives
in that part of the city. [chuckles] Right,
again so like I don't know what to do about
them but I know that [chuckles] you need to
have a somewhat more sophisticated view probably
driven by people and shaped by people who
know something about Russia.
The problem with Internet freedom agenda in
the State Department right now is that it's
so more or less articulated by people who
seem to know so much about the Internet, but
very little about the regional environments
and very little about the politics of Russia
and very little about the politics of China
and Iran. And that's why you run into all
of those geopolitical traps with the government
of Iran and China thinking that it was all
about Twitter and that's the company, it was
America's role, it was America's fault that
the protests happened.
So part of the argument I'm making in the
book is that the only way to reveal those
traps is to empower people with regional expertise,
it's not to empower Internet cores, it's not
to empower people who know everything about
Silicon Valley and like to point out because
there is a limit as to how much you can understand
about the Internet's impact on social change
and political change if all you know is how
the Internet works. You do need to know about
the social and political dynamics of those
countries.
>>Steve Grove: Let's go over here.
>>male #4: I think the number you threw out
before about the 60 ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>male #4: bloggers in Iran -- it's a little
misleading because ?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Uh-huh.
>>male #4: I think the reach is more important
rather than the actual bloggers. If everyone
is --
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>male #4: and then also I think you're always
going to see with something good that comes
out you're going to see such as with Iran
?
>>Evgeny Morozov: Yeah.
>>male #4: and you saw the oppressive government
using these technologies in a negative way.
You're always gonna see that but I don't think
that's an argument to not develop these and
promote these technologies.
>>Evgeny Morozov: Exactly, yes. I mean I'm
not saying that we should just shut down the
Internet and go back to the kind of the pre-digital
stage. To me the bigger question is how do
you get the policy right [inaudible]. And
I do think that there are there are worse
ways of going around setting policy on Internet
freedom and on such issues.
So [coughs] again I think the reason why we
need to look at the dark side in part because
we need to know who facilitates the dark side,
who makes it easier for the governments.
Now in Belarus, for example, where I come
from we had protests in December after the
presidential elections, just months ago. Now
there are reports that the government is actually
turning to mobile phone networks to the operators
of the mobile phones basically and demanding
them, demanding that they submit any data
and any information about their users who
may have shown up on the square at that time
so that the government can actually go and
track down all the dissidents who wanted to
oppose it, who wanted to protest against that.
And again I don't know what kind of technology
makes it possible. It may be that any mobile
phone company that has towers would be able
to identify who those people are. But then
they also want these companies to provide
the transcript of some conversations and text
messages traffic. And that technology was
probably sold to those companies by Ericsson.
Just like we saw in the case of Iran was a
technology sold to them by Nokia Siemens also
being exploited by the government. I don't
whether it was for the packet inspection or
if it was just for tracing the mobile phones
and calls.
So again to me the question, the reason why
we need to look to the dark side is to identify
how to minimize [chuckles] the government's
ability to profit from it and there are just
too many Western firms that make it possible,
right, and there are ways in which we can
minimize the kind of information and the amount
of information that the governments can collect.
>>Steve Grove: Thanks. And did you have data
on how many followers there were on those
60 bloggers?
>>Evgeny Morozov: It's data that came from
Al Jazeera so I don't even know if they disclosed.
I mean it would be silly for Al Jazeera to
disclose who those people were in part because
the government can go and arrest them.
But then I take your point I mean it doesn?t
matter how people you have on the ground because
they can amplify because of the network effect
and whatnot, but again the narrative that
you saw, the reason why I quote the stat in
the book is because the narrative we saw in
the Western media made it seem as if every
second Iranian had a mobile phone from which
they were Tweeting, right. It was not that
Twitter didn't play some role. Of course it
played some role in publicizing what was happening,
but the dominant narrative in the Western
media was that, "Hey all of the Iranians organized
online. They all were on Twitter and each
of them was Tweeting from the square," and
then that's ?
>>Steve Grove: Um-hum.
>>Evgeny Morozov: that's just not what was
happening.